all right hello everyone welcome to
another episode of science and
technology q a for kids and others
i started doing these
when the pandemic set in
and my original concept was
that there were all sorts of kids who
were not in school at that time and this
was kind of
a way of providing some hopefully
interesting content
uh to fill in for that
that story is is rather over at this
point um but i've continued doing this
because i find it interesting people
seem to like it i learn lots from it
but i would like to get input from
people
on what kinds of things they would like
to hear about or see here
i think i'm going to
uh there are questions where i've
already answered them and i think we're
going to mostly point people to the
existing answers when that happens
um
and
i also might talk a little bit more
about things that i think i'm probably
uniquely able to talk about
um
although i always find it interesting to
try and explain things that uh in
principle you could find explained
elsewhere but somehow i end up having
different explanations than you would
often find
kind of reminds me of uh
a little bit um
my
uh old friend a physicist named richard
feynman who was uh quite famous who
wrote a collection of lectures on
physics
uh
based on the world for in the early
1960s and i remember him telling me that
when he had first
had uh
he he
presented physics in kind of very much
his own way
which was a an interesting and very
intuitive way um but when he was first
giving those lectures he had some
students taking notes from them
and
he told me that they'd come to him
and said well you know in your lectures
you explained this thing in this way but
professor feynman
we think that the standard way of doing
it is what you wanted and so we changed
it to be the standard way of of
explaining this thing and he was like oh
my gosh no don't do that
the whole point is to explain it in a
way that hasn't been explained before so
so after that he got some fairly
distinguished professors actually to
take
take the notes for his lectures and
that's what turned into a fairly famous
collection of physics textbooks but so
even when one's asking about something
that is kind of a thing you could find
the answer an answer in a textbook
i often find that i end up talking about
things that aren't at all what you would
find in the textbook but are hopefully
interesting and good ways to understand
what's going on so i'm perfectly happy
to try and address those questions
because i learn a bunch from them as
well
all right well with that said um
let's see we have a number of questions
saved up from last time but please feel
free to ask about um any kind of science
physics biology uh
any kind of mathematics technology
computer technology other kinds of
technology uh you may may hit things i
don't know about but um uh that if if so
um well so it goes but um there'll
probably be a bunch of stuff where i'll
i'll know things and might have
something uh interesting i hope to say
all right there was a question here
saved up from before from aaron
asking could you build a reverse natural
language understanding engine one that
would take computer code and output
natural language explaining what the
code is doing
okay so first of all let's talk about
what the pieces of that mean so by
natural language we mean languages like
english and french and whatever that
people speak
and
the one of the things that has been an
achievement
of recent times is the ability to
understand natural language to have
computers understand natural language
and and probably the most sophisticated
such thing is our wolfram alpha uh
knowledge engine
that um also uh does the
computational knowledge for things like
syria and so on um but uh
the the the point of alpha is to take
something you ask in natural language
which is something like uh
what's the density of gold compared to
lead let's say and you use english words
to ask the question and then its goal is
to answer that question perhaps to
compute the answer you know what's the
distance to the planet jupiter right now
what's the distance between jupiter and
saturn right now that requires both
understanding the question
and being able to compute the answer to
the question
so what wolfman alfred does
is it takes the natural language that
you've given it and what it wants to do
is to convert that natural language into
a computational language where it can
actually understand how to do the
computations where it has a sort of
precise specification of what that
language means
and part of the reason that we were able
to build wolfmaffer which came out in
2009
um was that
uh and people have been trying to build
kind of question answering systems as
sort of exercises as artificial
intelligence for many decades before
that and had not really gotten terribly
far
the reason that we were able to do it
was because we had another component
that was huge and very critical which
was we already had a computational
language
into which these natural language
questions could be turned so when you
say
what's the distance between jupiter and
saturn for example
we have a representation
in our wolfram language computational
language of the planet jupiter the
planet saturn the notion of their
positions the distance between them the
difference in distance but difference in
position between them and a distance
between those things we can represent
that question
in a computational language so it might
say you know entity planet jupiter and
it might say something like actually i
don't exactly know how to do this but
but um i think it would be uh uh that
thing of uh
i don't know position and then that will
give you a set of coordinates those
coordinates are probably relative to the
center of the sun
but then given those two sets of
coordinates you would be finding the
euclidean distance let's say between
those planets and that will give you
some some quantity and then that that's
the answer that's perhaps a more
elaborate uh type of question but the
point is that all of those pieces like
in our wolfram language uh that's what
makes it sort of a computational
language instead of a programming
language is its ability to actually
understand computationally things about
the world like the concept of the planet
jupiter or things about positions of
planets and so on and to be able to deal
with that as something that is intrinsic
to the language
as opposed to a programming language
where ones like c or java or python or
something where one is uh
just dealing with things which a
computer intrinsically knows about where
that are to do with the actual structure
of the computer and the intrinsic
operations that a piece of computer
hardware does as opposed to things that
are
facts about the world or procedures for
computing things in the world which is
the kind of thing that we've spent the
last uh well three or four decades um
making happen making work in our world
from language computational language but
okay so the thing with wolfman alpha is
going from natural language to
computational language once we have a
question asked in computational language
then it's up to the implementation of
the computational language and all the
sources of data and algorithms and so on
to be able to actually answer the
question and then we have another
component of alpha which is the ability
to synthesize sort of a report that
shows you uh the the things you might
want to know about the answer to that
question but the the key piece is we're
going from
from natural language into our
computational language and doing that is
a whole collection of algorithms and
whole collection of heuristics kinds of
ways to
to uh sort of guess things in an
informed fashion
that take sort of uh things about the
structure of natural language
and
sort of break them apart and turn them
into something that we can understand as
part of our computational language so
for example you might say
i don't know
uh let's take um
uh
oh simple example um
something like well take the planet
jupiter okay so i might say the planet
jupiter or i might just say jupiter if i
say jupiter on its own that might mean
the town of jupiter florida it might
mean uh
some uh some other uh i'm sure there's
companies and products named jupiter or
it might mean the uh uh the roman uh god
jupiter um
the so there's
we've got to be able to understand from
the natural language of the word jupiter
we've got to understand what it is maybe
we said the planet jupiter or or jupiter
the planet or maybe we said um uh
the um but but we we we can get a clue
from kind of how we refer to jupiter we
can also get a clue from other things
we're asking about like distance to
jupiter okay well that could be distance
to jupiter florida or it could be
distance the planet jupiter by the time
it's some distance
from
jupiter to miami
well that's probably jupiter florida if
it's distance from jupiter to saturn or
distance from jupiter to earth
well that's that's pretty certainly the
planet
so these are kinds of things and in the
natural language understanding that we
do in wolfram alpha it's kind of an
elaborate set of ideas that have to do
with for example different probabilities
of different things that might be
what one's talking about
usually those probabilities resolve very
very quickly usually by the time there's
a decent number of words in the natural
language one is really nailed is it
jupiter florida or jupiter of the planet
or jupiter of the god
um and so on but
in any case so that that's that's the
process of going from natural language
to computational language now the
question was being asked here was a
different question which is if you've
got a piece of code maybe it's
programming language code maybe it's
computational language code if you've
got a piece of code
then can you explain
in natural language what that code is
doing
okay so having spent a large part of my
life as a designer of computational
language i would say
if you need to explain it
that's a sign that your language was not
designed correctly
so for example if you have something
where you've got a piece of i don't know
c code
for i equals zero i less than ten i plus
plus
uh you know j equals i times i or
something let's say that's the piece of
code
now
i might explain that piece of code by
annotating it oh i plus plus means
increment i after this happens or this
for loop has a test that does this or
that
it's that's perhaps not a good example
because it's comparatively simple but
the issue is a language that is the the
goal of a language designer is to make
this bridge between what humans readily
understand
and
what is precisely specified in a way
that computers can do something with it
and
if you do something where humans can't
readily understand it you're not doing
good language design you can say as
people often do
oh but i want to set up the language
that way because it makes it easier for
the computer
and in the early days of programming
languages back in the late 1950s early
1960s that was an important thing
computer time was vastly more expensive
than programmer time and it was really
important to kind of optimize
what the computer did over all of that
effort the programmer might have to
spend to figure out how to write the
right program
well that has long ago flipped around
dramatically and what's relevant now is
can the programmer understand what to do
can they do it correctly can they write
a program that is likely to do what they
want as opposed to you know the program
will always do what the program does the
question is does the program do what you
had in mind to want the program to do
because if you write the program and the
program doesn't do what you thought it
should do then you'll say well my
program has a bug
but the program does what the program
was written down to do so to speak the
program it's just that what you wrote
the program down to do isn't what you
thought
about having the program do so to speak
so
i think the the the main point is that
when you are trying to write a program
the goal is
to have a language in which you can as
directly as possible take things the way
you think about them
and write them down so that you can have
the computer execute them and so one of
the issues is if you are dealing with a
very low level language that is a
language very close to the raw
operations of the computer
the computer doesn't even know about
something like the for loop that i
mentioned from the c programming
language it knows about things like set
this value in this register in the cpu
of the computer move this data from here
to here take the data from this memory
location in that memory location and add
these together that's what the computer
intrinsically knows about and the lowest
level that you can program a computer is
its machine code where you're just
saying there are certain set of
operations that the computer
intrinsically knows how to do maybe 100
of them like adding things moving data
from memory and the level of machine
code you're saying op code number 37
uh
use that operate on memory location
numbered such and such and memory and
register numbers such and such
that's what the raw machine code of the
computer looks like then you get to a
samurai language where you start to be
able to have names for things and then
you get to the lower level languages
like c and so on um where you have um
uh where you can use
things like where you can have a
slightly more sort of human readable
version
of the specification of what the
computer is doing but in the end it's
fairly direct to go from c code to what
is actually the machine code of the
computer it's a fairly direct process of
compiling it you just take the c program
and you're converting it down to machine
code so to speak
these days usually through a couple of
intermediate levels
but
in any case the and so in a sense the
way computers are set up they're set up
to work the way they work
uh they with some effort to to sort of
pander to the humans but mostly they
start to work the way they work to be as
efficient as possible to take the kinds
of computations uh to to be efficient in
in running through different kinds of
computations and to be something that
can be readily implemented in computer
hardware and one should not forget there
is a certain tradition in history to the
way that computers get set up which
really hasn't changed much in more than
50 years now and and there's a certain
and there's a whole sort of chain of
technology of compilers and all these
kinds of things that are all built on
top of a certain set of assumptions
about how computers are intrinsically
constructed and how the the operations
and in c computer cpus work that's why
for example if somebody says well we're
going to introduce new kinds of computer
operations that's a a huge kind of issue
of building sort of a a whole depth of
tooling for computers to be able to deal
with that
well any case so when we're dealing with
languages that so so a language like c
is is a pretty well designed language
for what it is which is kind of a
wrapper around the intrinsic operations
of the machine
and those wrappers get a little thicker
so a big issue is memory management when
you have the
if you are going to say i've got an
array of data
a let's say a list of numbers and it's
of length a thousand or something
and you say i want to store that in the
memory of the computer okay you've got
to allocate a thousand elements of
memory to store that array okay well
maybe you stop using that array
sometimes so you've got to say okay i
don't need to use that that those
thousand elements of memory anymore
let's give them back to the operating
system and let another part of my
program or another program altogether
make use of those those elements of
memory and so the process of of like
managing memory like that of saying oh
i'm using this thing i've stopped using
it etc etc etc something like the c
programming language basically doesn't
do any of that
well it does a little bit of it when
you're when you're calling functions it
has this notion of the function stack
where that happens but when you're
allocating memory to just work with it
it doesn't do those kinds of things
um one of the sort of innovations of
slightly higher level languages is that
they have various ways of somewhat
automatically dealing with the
allocation and deallocation of memory
when you're using wolfram language for
example you never would see anything
about memory allocation and deallocation
that's that's many many many layers
below
what an actual human user is exposed to
and
just just not a thing that comes up
and uh
so
the the thing that um uh when you're
talking about
taking a piece of programming language
code it might contain things about
memory allocation it might contain all
kinds of things representing different
kinds of data structures of saying how
do you
represent this two-dimensional array is
it a is it a list of of of
one-dimensional array elements is it
something which is indexed into in with
two variables or with one combined in a
sort of in a positional notation kind of
thing you know how does that all work
and that's all a lot of that tends to be
explicitly exposed in typical
programming languages
so
the um
and
so the question then is if you've got a
piece of programming language code it
may be hard to understand
the and you might say well let's
annotate it by giving natural language
and sort of making uh sort of
automatically generating comments about
what the code is doing
well the goal of something like well
from language
is to not have that make any sense to
have it be the case that what you write
in the actual computational language
itself is the clearest expression that
you can give of what you want to do and
anything you might give saying this is
doing this that's doing that
is going to be largely irrelevant
and when it's a question of saying often
it's useful in understanding a piece of
a piece of code to sort of think of it
in a modular way say this piece is doing
this this piece is doing this now you
fit them together that's the way that we
will typically explain and talk about
things we don't just have a sentence
that's uh i don't know you know we don't
have a a 400 word sentence that would be
very very hard to understand with lots
of subclauses and so on uh some
philosophers um uh of the past
particularly were were fond of writing
these monumentally long sentences which
are extremely hard to understand
you know we tend to break things up into
smaller sentences paragraphs things like
that because our brains seem to do much
better at processing things when they're
sort of presented in this modular
hierarchical kind of way
and it's the same kind of thing with
with programming language and
computational language that it's
typically useful to break things up and
one does that by writing lots of little
functions and one gives those functions
names
and those names are a very important
clue for us humans about what's going on
it's like we could say
uh you know i mentioned the the sort of
the machine code of a computer might be
op code number 37 op code number 38
but those things are you know add
multiply as soon as you call them add
and multiply it's like oh yeah i know
what that is
it would be like
if i were talking in english in natural
language and instead of
naming things instead of saying you know
an elephant and a turtle i would say
species number 642 species number 875
it would be super difficult for us to
understand that because the way that our
brains are set up we use things like
words and nouns and so on as kind of
keys into just this whole kind of a
bundle of knowledge that we have about
these different kinds of things so when
you're writing a program one of the
things that is quite important is try to
come up with sort of names for the
functions you use first of all build
make your program out of lots of little
separate functions and then name those
functions according to the thing that
you will want to think about uh that
that is a description of what that
function is doing
now one of the classics of programming
is most essentially all languages have
this notion of comments
you're writing your code and you can put
a comment something which will be
ignored by the computer but it's just
intended for a human who's reading that
piece of code
so you know in wolfram language it'll be
paren star and then you have some piece
of text that is your comment and you end
up with a star paren and and that's a um
and when when the wolfram language
system comes to look at that piece of
code just gonna say i don't care about
that that's only for the humans
okay
now the classic thing about uh
programming language uh
about coding and software engineering is
people write a big lump of code and
they'll write a comment
the code will be correct
but the comment will be misleading and
perhaps wrong
and in a sense writing comments
is its own kind of exercise in
programming writing comments but usually
people aren't taking don't take the
comments as seriously as they take their
code and so it's really common for
comments to be extremely misleading and
even simply incorrect
i might say that in this in this kind of
thing about how you write code
one of the other areas happens to be
something i'm thinking about right now
is you write a piece of code that is
intended to do what you intend it to do
but there might be some error case it
might be
that i don't know you're trying to
figure out uh
i don't know population density of
animals based on certain data
but the animal is not aquatic and in the
ocean it should be zero and something
goes wrong in that case instead of a
corner case you didn't think of
and um it's
you know i just didn't think of the case
where the animal can't live there
because it's an ocean type thing
whatever else in writing your code
that's sort of an error case that's not
part of the main uh
um the main kind of code path that
you're using and error cases will be
less thought about than the main code
path because the main code path is what
you expect the program mostly to do
and so the error case is something where
you kind of need a net to catch what
happens if you go into the error case
but you're not going to spend all that
effort to deal with the error case
because it's an unusual corner case that
you think isn't going to happen
so it's some uh
um
the um
the thing that
uh
the thing that um
um
the thing that happens is people people
put less effort into this kind of um
uh
um
into um
uh into writing the what happens in the
error case than they do in the what
happens in the standard code path one of
the things i always find amusing is
you you'll see messages that people
write for errors and one of the ones
that comes up from time to time and
programs people write is it'll say
something like impossible error like it
printed it out it's like it's possible
it knows it's possible to print it out
but it's basically saying this error
cannot happen what does that mean it
means the programmer could not imagine a
case in which this error could happen
but actually it just did happen you got
to see it
um
it uh
it reminds me i have to tell a little
bit of a story from a long time ago in
the 1970s when i was using a big
mainframe computer the size of a large
room that uh you program with with punch
cards and things like that
and it was a big ibm mainframe computer
and uh
i run this program and it got some error
and you know usually in those days the
errors were
were given designations like you know
ieh2036 or something the error didn't
tell you what the error actually was it
just said you know
ieh3026 or something and so to find out
what the error was you had to look
through this big uh you know uh
shelf-sized uh documentation for the
error
and um so i i did that for some error
that i got and there were pages and
pages of errors and i finally get to the
error that was the error that i
had got and the only explanation for the
error was
probable user error
so that's like totally useless
what was going on the point was the vast
majority of those errors were things
that could go wrong with the computer as
a piece of computer hardware not
something we see much today um and the
case of oh it was the programmer who
made a mistake that was kind of like oh
that's that's you know that we don't
have to worry about that case the cases
of interest that were mostly documented
were things that could go wrong with the
computer anyway things have changed
since then but now the question is
can we generate the original question
here is can we go from a piece of
programming language code to an
explanation of what this code is doing i
would say my number one answer to how to
do that is write your code in more from
language instead um that that then then
you will have something where the
language was actually designed to be
able to explain what the code was doing
if you're writing in a low-level
language which was mostly for the
benefit of the computer then it's not
surprising the human can't understand it
now having said that there are things
like for example can you automatically
generate a reasonable name for a
function
we've done lots of experiments on this
using machine learning trying to learn
from existing code corpora things like
this it's really hard that's something
humans are decent at but it's really
hard to do that automatically so
actually humans are not that good at it
humans often do a surprisingly bad job
actually coming up with reasonable names
for their functions because
they have in their mind the thing they
were thinking about at the moment they
wrote the function which was one kind of
use of that function they don't have in
mind some other use they they kind of
their thinking has been dragged in some
particular direction and they're not
thinking more boldly
another case
is could you automatically generate a
reasonable message saying what went
wrong in this piece of code
that's a little closer to being possible
i think and we've been doing a bunch of
experiments on that um there are a bunch
of the a thing that is much more
possible
is when you type in the code
can you guess whether this is a
reasonably likely piece of code for
somebody to want to type in
um and that's something where you can
use information on sort of the
statistics
of what
people typically write in code like this
to be able to guess that it's much like
spell checking in principle you might
want to spell some word in some totally
funky way because it's a new use of that
word but chances are you don't want to
do that and so the spell checker is
telling you that
and so i think that's a that that's a
kind of thing which which one can do
um the uh the other thing that i've been
very interested in
is uh the question of if you run a piece
of code and it gives the wrong answer
can you
synthesize an explanation for why the
answer was the way it was given that you
told it i really should have got 11 but
the code actually gave 96 or something
you you say it was supposed to be 11.
and the question is can you ever figure
out can you try to figure out uh how
would it have gotten to 11 what did you
get wrong an important thing to notice
in um
another thing we've been interested in
is code simplification you write a piece
of code and it's got all kinds of little
pieces in it and so on and you say
simplify this piece of code like you
might say if you have an algebraic
expression and you have the expression i
don't know um uh
x plus 1 times x minus 2 times x plus 3
times whatever you might say can you
simplify that or maybe divided by a
bunch of things can you simplify it oh
yes i can do an algebraic transformation
and the answer is x cubed minus 3 or
something
and so i take this big long algebraic
expression and that's equal to x cubed
minus 3 and i can discover that by doing
mathematical transformations so the
question is can you do the same kind of
thing with computer code say well you
the programmer wrote this as a as a
10-line piece of code but actually
there's a way to rearrange it so that
it's only two lines long
and
if one's lucky it's two lines that
really explain what the point is much
more clearly they really are like a good
piece of exposition in english they are
explaining the point in a way that's
clear so that then you will understand
what's going on and maybe the code will
even run more efficiently i should have
said by the way in terms of this
question of what does the code do
that you can write code in a kind of
sloppy way just as you can write english
in a sloppy way and it's really pretty
hard to understand
you know i could invent as i'm trying to
explain things to to you all
uh you know part of what i try to do
is structure the explanation in a
certain way like say the main point
explain the point etc etc etc it's it's
not hard
to end up in a situation where you are
not explaining things in a way that has
that kind of structure and where it's
really hard to understand what's going
on let me give you an example that comes
up in wolfman alpha actually and in
syria and so on let's say i ask
what's the population of new york city
and the answer is
uh something like
um
uh 18 million seven hundred and twenty
six thousand three hundred and forty
four
and that's the answer
now
that answer is actually when you just
hear that
or or maybe we can even make it more
complicated and and and have a string of
numbers that come out
that answer is probably not the easiest
to understand answer
um
the you know a better answer would be
the population is about 18 million
or more exactly blah blah blah blah you
know
and and then maybe there are additional
footnotes like based on the previous
census data blah blah blah but saying
it's roughly 18 million or more exactly
blah blah blah is a much more human
uh absorbable explanation than let's
just jump right into the details and go
start saying the details right up front
and that that's you know characteristic
of of expository writing is that you
have to have some of these kind of
structural uh elements to help people
understand things you know one of the
things that um i could i could yakk on
about this for ages about expository
writing because i've done quite a lot of
it in my life um the uh you know one of
the things when you're writing things
like uh documentation for uh
computational kinds of things
uh and other and and there's some other
places where this happens as well
is for example
there may be a main point the critical
point
if the critical point is said in four
words even if those words are really
clear
halfway down the page
nobody's going to notice
you kind of have to you know one of my
theories of computer documentation is
the importance of a point should be
roughly proportional to the actual area
it takes up on the page of talking about
it so if the point is important you've
got to find ways to kind of puff it up
so people really notice that that point
is being made rather than just oh it's
in those four words that are really
clear but you probably missed them
and and similarly it's important
sometimes as you explain things to be
able to say
uh
to make meta comments like this is the
really important point
or this is a detailed point you don't
really need to it's kind of like a
detail it's important to signpost those
kinds of things because that's important
for exposition now when you're
presenting a piece of of code uh the the
question is can you can you sort of
simplify code to make it more
expositorily more more clear in its
exposition and the answer is you can do
some of that and one of the things you
find if you do program simplification
program simplification is very hard it's
very hard thing to do but you can do at
least certain cases of it
one of the things you find is somebody
writes a piece of code
and you try and simplify it you do it in
more from language
and you'll find well the simplified
piece of code is mostly just this one
function that says you know reverse the
transpose of this thing or whatever it
is
but then it's got a little extra case
hanging off the end if blah blah blah is
less than this then do this thing and
that's the extra case that hangs off the
end so it's mostly just there's this
very simple thing with a couple of
functions but then there are these
special cases hanging off the end okay
in a well-designed computational
language it's probably the case that
those special cases are bugs
that they're things the programmer
didn't think of but they're things where
the design the intrinsic design of the
language would do what you actually want
to do and you have to special case those
things where you're doing something
different from what the language thought
you wanted to do so that's in a sense
it's a great way to find bugs
is you simplify the program and if
you've got weird little extra pieces
hanging off the end those are things you
need to look at very carefully because
they're corner cases that you probably
didn't get right
so
in any case i i think that this um this
kind of effort of uh
can you create a um
uh something where you can um
uh given that you wrote a piece of code
you get the wrong answer um you know can
you kind of uh say why is it that answer
not the one i expected i think it is
possible in the next few years that we
will be able to do some of that
and in what language would you express
the
why did it go wrong that's an
interesting question
for example when you give a mathematical
proof
there is a certain there's a question of
how do you give the proof there might be
a mathematical result that you know this
particular
uh that this the prime number you know
this
this you know 2 to the prime number of
this is always equal to this that might
be the result and you might be able to
express that result quite easily in
mathematical notation but the proof of
that result is something that
on its face is not expressible in
mathematical notation instead the proof
will be an explanation that might be a
mixture of things in english and some
math and et cetera et cetera et cetera
so the the representation of a proof is
already a difficult thing and we've been
interested in that actually for a very
long time in wolfram language and we
finally have there's a function called
find equation of proof which generates a
kind of structure that represents a
proof but we're not super happy with it
now actually this process of
representing a proof
is like it's like representing the
intermediate steps of a computation and
for example in our model of physics
all of the things we're experiencing in
the world in physics and the progress of
time are just like intermediate steps of
the big computation that is the one
being done by our universe so in a sense
what we experience is exactly the
innards of a computation being done but
the general question when we've written
when we've described the computation
most of what we want to do in more than
language is here's a question get me the
answer here's the input crunch crunch
crunch get the output
expressing representing the intermediate
steps is an interesting problem that's a
completely unsolved problem it's it's a
problem that's not even been solved for
low-level programming languages let
alone a sophisticated computational
language like ours and in fact perhaps
it will be easier because in our
computational language it is our goal to
represent everything and representing
the progress of a computation
is part of the story of everything so to
speak and in fact we we have i mean i
make it sound like we don't have
anything figured out about this actually
quite recently we've been working on
this and trying to use ideas from our
physics project to represent kind of the
the progress of computations the way
that sort of events happen in
computations and what that sort of flow
of
of of kind of of data is through the
computation
so that's a sort of a coming attraction
but we don't yet have a good language to
describe sort of what happens inside a
program
and um the
and so i suppose that's sort of a
prerequisite
for describing you sort of describing an
actual program running we can say this
is the program but now we run the
program and the program is going to do a
lot of things internally we don't have a
great way to represent that sort of
space-time diagram of the running of the
program we can say here is the program
here is the input here's the output but
the actual sort of progress of the
program we don't have a great way to
represent that and that's something
we're working on
i think that
then the question of the why did my
program do the wrong thing
ends up being why did you get this
space-time diagram basically rather than
that one and perhaps that's the way to
think about sort of the process of of of
seeing what's wrong i mean it's a little
bit like
sometimes the
the uh
wrong answer as well in in human
computation wrong answers usually give
you a lot more information than right
answers so for example i don't know if
somebody does an arithmetic problem you
know they're
doing long multiplication of two numbers
and they get the right answer okay great
they got the right answer there could be
many methods by which they got that
answer it's all good let's say they get
the wrong answer
well there are many many wrong answers
you could have given you know let's say
it's a five digit number there are you
know a million wrong answers that you
could have given in addition to the
single right answer so if you look at
the wrong answer you can quite possibly
backtrack to figure out what did they do
wrong did they miss copy of four for a
nine or something somewhere in the
intermediate stages you can actually
figure out we did a little project on
this at one time you can actually do for
for like additional multiplication you
can actually do a pretty decent job
usually given the wrong answer of
backtracking to find out what did the
person do wrong and and then so that's
sort of an example of something a little
bit like the computational case although
it's in a more limited domain of of uh
of of things
all right long answer there okay we've
got a bunch of other questions here
let's see
all right
as a question here
um
from
uh gologaz
suggestions on program problems and and
cases to use for introductory
programming
well i mean you know i've spent the last
40 years basically building our wolfram
language computational language system
which
is
i mean i would like to say it's a
computational language but it is the
world's only full-scale computational
language and that's sort of 40 years of
work that's that's got it to that point
and nothing else has really been
building in that direction so i would i
would it would be much easier if i could
just say a computational language like
all the other ones that you already know
about but i can't say that
but kind of the goal with with wolfram
language as i mentioned is to be able to
have a way to describe things in the
world computationally and when people
want to use computers that's what they
ultimately want to do is they want to be
able to deal with things in the world
computationally so to speak them it
could be in the abstract world but they
want to be able to deal with things they
care about computationally and the sort
of traditional view of low-level
programming which is the one that came
from sort of the early days of computing
from 60 years ago and so on
is
let's learn how to write things that are
precisely how the computer works it's
like let's not learn to drive a car by
pressing you know the gas pedal and
driving the steering wheel let's learn
how to actually pump you know things
into the carburetor and and do the uh
you know have the um
have fuel go into the into the cylinders
and things like that
uh we don't need to know that stuff
anymore for computers it is many layers
below
what you actually need to know it might
be interesting you might care about it
it's something to study but it's not
something if you are wanting to use
computation to do things it's just not
stuff you need to know about
so in terms of of what you can do to
learn about computation
you know i wrote a little book called
elementary introduction to wolfram
language which you can find on the web
and you can find moocs around it and
things like that um uh i i would suspect
that um uh well the the the demographic
for uh people watching this and people
for whom my elementary introduction book
is relevant is probably an intersecting
demographic at least um i wrote that i'm
entry introduction book to be suitable
for high school students and and others
it's been used a lot by the others as
well
um but uh it's it's intended for those
kinds of uh those kinds of folk and it's
kind of uh it
tries to explain how to do computation
for dealing with images or sounds or
maps or
just arrays of numbers or whatever else
and that's a good place to start
and then it's just take something that
you
think is interesting in the world
whether it's some data from the world
whether it's something some operation
you want to do so to speak and think how
do i represent that computationally and
then
if i and we did a good job designing
wolfram language then that's something
you should be able to rather directly
use in our do in our language and the
elementary introduction book should get
you to the point where you're able to do
that for a pretty wide class of things
or at least able to know the principles
by which you can do that usually the
difficult part is
is to take what you're thinking about
and know how to think about it
computationally so that you can feed it
to the computational language um but
that's a part that is sort of the the
human step that's a part where us humans
are the ones that really have to do that
because we're the ones who know what we
want to do and that's the part to learn
but the the pure skill aspect
of knowing given that i've
conceptualized something uh
computationally how do i actually get it
to the computer well for example my
elementary introduction book is probably
a good a good bridge for that piece
let's see we've got a math question here
from
guests
why is it harder to compute integrals
than derivatives
um
well this is one of these cases where
if i sort of broke my rule of just
talking to you guys and started actually
typing something on a computer it might
be a little easier but i'll see what i
can do just uh just talking about this
so
uh just just a little bit of a refresher
for people on derivatives and integrals
in general
the um
uh
it's what one's doing is one has some
function
f of x
so what does that mean what means you
know f of x could be
i don't know the um
uh
let's let's say it could be um
uh the
the i'm trying well okay the most
obvious thing is it's f of t where t is
time
and f represents the position of a thing
as a function of time so something is
moving around as a function of time and
you can draw that as a curve where the
distance it goes is you know it goes
forwards it goes backwards et cetera et
cetera et cetera
and the derivative is the slope of that
curve
which means in the case of something
moving
you know where where the curve is
representing position as a function of
time the derivative is the velocity
the the the speed of the thing it's the
it's the rate of change of position with
time
uh that's that's the first derivative of
this function sometimes written f prime
of of t f dot uh sometimes written d f
of t divided by dt that's a very
confusing notation invented by leibniz
in the late 1600s where even he knew the
day he invented it that was a confusing
notation but it's still with us 300 and
something years later in any case so
that's so derivative is the slope of the
function the rate of change of the
function the integral is the area
under the under the curve uh in in some
fields like in medicine for example what
is in mathematics usually called the
integral is usually called auc the area
under the curve um and that's um
and that will tell you uh if what we
were plotting
was instead the velocity then the area
under the curve would give us the
position
um and so that that um uh the one of the
points about integrals and derivatives
is they're basically inverses of each
other if you know the area under the
curve the rate of change of the area
under the curve is the actual position
of the original curve
um
so and that's true up to a constant
where because you could have said well
the area under the curve includes all
the stuff to the left but that's not
relevant for um uh uh for working when
you work out the the slope of that
you're you're dropping that piece but so
the basic concept is the the derivative
is working out the slope the uh
the integral is working out the area and
they're inverses of each other in the
sense that the derivative of an integral
is equal to the thing you started from
the integral of derivative is the thing
you started from up to some constants
okay so given that description
why would it be harder to work out the
derivative work out the integral than
work out the derivative
um
the the reason is that when you write
down mathematical expressions
the story is different the story there
are tricks for working out derivatives
and the most important trick is the
thing called the chain rule
and basically the point is this if you
have some function g
g of t
and you say f of g of t
so that means you compute g of t and
then you can take the result of that and
you compute f of that
okay so
it then turns out
that if you want to find the rate of
change of f of g of t
then that can be broken gosh i haven't
thought about this by hand in a million
years i feel like i have to type this
into all the language if i'm going to
actually know the right answer but but
basically what happens is
that that thing you know i feel like i
have to type this in otherwise i'm
literally going to tell you the wrong
thing because i i never think about this
by hand
and
it's
when
i have to say one of those unendearing
things when you see a kid
tight you know doing um
doing their calculus homework you say
you know i didn't think um
uh
i didn't think humans still did that
kind of thing but anyway so so anyway
what what happens the chain rule so f of
g of x
essentially you can break apart
the
the the change of g and the change of f
and so the the change of the whole thing
is
f prime
i'm reading it off the screen now
because i to make sure i i know this one
but um uh
you know f prime of g of of t
times
g prime of t so in other words the the
the the sort of the final answer
is
the rate of change of each nested piece
multiplied together
so the reason derivatives are easier to
work out is because you can take apart
any mathematical expression you can
think about it as kind of a nested
collection of functions it's like the
and in fact a more than language if you
say what's x cubed
times
1 plus x or something that will be the
times
of power of x comma three
comma and then the plus of whatever i
said one and x
so you know so it's it's represented
even at the uh any mathematical
expression is represented as this kind
of pre-structured thing and then the
derivative can always be gotten by just
using the chain rule that that's this
rule which says the derivative of this
nested collection of functions is the
product of essentially the changes of
the individual functions separated so
it's a very systematic procedure that
lets you take this mathematical
expression represented as symbolic
mathematical expression represented in
this kind of tree-like form of functions
of functions of functions and then you
take the derivative and all those
individual functions have their
changings that they're doing and you
what the results you get are essentially
based on products of those of those
individual changes
okay that's how it works for derivatives
for integrals no such thing is true the
integral of something is sort of a
puzzle where you have to say well let me
figure it out so that i get the right
derivative but there's no systematic
procedure like the chain rule for
finding integrals well that's more or
less true it's not it's a at a
sophisticated level it isn't quite true
so
when you find the integral there are
rules you know like the integral of uh i
don't know x to the power n is x to the
power n plus one divided by n plus one
um that's uh you know that's just a rule
you know um and there are lots of other
such rules um that that one knows but
the problem is that unlike for
derivatives where once you know one of
those rules you can use it for that
individual part of the expression and
the thing you get for the whole
expression is just sort of the the
nesting of all those rules there's no
such similar sort of rule of combination
for integrals well there's a there's a
integration by parts is sort of a little
bit like that but it doesn't work in the
same kind of everything falls apart kind
of way it's just a rather specific thing
for for products of two elements
so
it's um uh and the other thing that
happens is when you're doing derivatives
because you can look at each part
separately it's kind of a limit to how
complicated things can get in the case
of an integral because it's sort of
everything together you sometimes can
get these very elaborate ornate
complicated functions which are the
solution to that puzzle of what do you
need to produce that whose derivative
will be the original thing you started
from
and and so
that um uh that there's sort of a a one
of the things about doing integrals um
is can you if you can guess what the
general form of the integral is oh i
know that would be a log integral
function multiplied by
some logarithms with some powers of x
and so on if you know that general form
you have a fighting chance because you
can just find that general form fill in
parameters a b c d
for the the you know i don't know which
power it is i don't know how many of
these there are et cetera et cetera et
cetera my notes of this form you take
that general form you find the
derivative which is straightforward to
do which also will involve those
parameters you say is there a way of
matching up those parameters so that it
will agree with what i had as the thing
i was trying to do as an integral i have
to say when when i used to do integrals
um
by hand
um
the um
uh
the back
oh 40 something years ago um before i uh
before i switched to always doing both
computers
that was that must have been
1977 that i made that switch
um
the uh
uh that that's why i get to have to type
in the the chain rule because i'm not
sure i remember exactly right but in any
case the um
the thing that um
uh
uh people when they learn to do
integrals by hand
they often learn all of these tricks
for you know uh com i don't know
i don't even remember what these tricks
are trig substitutions uh all sorts of
tricks
and those tricks
tend to be it's sort of a pattern
matching thing to figure out what trick
can i use in this case
this idea of guests the general form of
the integral and then match it up is a
pretty good general trick which i don't
think they ever teach to people but it's
a really good thing if you're actually
confronted with here's an integral you
have to do it's a if you can guess the
general form by the way in modern times
there's the potential for machine
learning to be a useful way to try and
guess general forms like that
i i should say that when one actually
does integrals sort of uh for real so to
speak one of the one of the things like
in welfare language the way we do
integrals is
we actually convert
things to much more sophisticated
mathematical functions so you have an
integral that's involving sine and
logarithm functions and so on we convert
that to an integral involving things
called may or g functions usually which
are some very generalized kinds of
mathematical functions and given that
it's converted the integrand is
converted into that form there's a very
general way that you can do integrals of
all such functions and then the real
challenge is can you take the answer you
get and turn it into something that is
recognizable by humans as mathematical
functions they would want so to speak
and that that ends up being the main
challenge but it's a very typical thing
in doing integrals that uh you start off
with a very you know simple function
like i don't know what's a good example
um
integral of log one plus x over x
uh what is that well you might say oh
right that's a surely i can do that
integral i must have learnt how to do
that integral in an elementary calculus
class well actually no that integral
comes out in terms of a thing called the
dialogue function which they never talk
about in elementary calculus classes and
it's very easy to go from from something
like that to a um to something where
it's where it's a very complicated
function or a different you're in a new
kind of class of functions classic
example of this well the integral of
sine x
is um
uh sine x is is cos x
um
and uh but the integral of sine of sine
of x
is really difficult
and that comes out i think we can now
finally after 30 something years that's
an integral we can finally do and it
comes out in terms of a pell f1 function
which is a generalized multivariate
hypergeometric function it's a really
complicated story but what's what
happens with integrals is this whole
thing of there may not be a way okay so
i should explain
you know it's not even obvious that
there will be a function that has a name
that anybody's ever talked about that
before that would be the thing that
represents the integral of sine of sine
of x it could be that this integral just
can't be done
in terms of the class of functions you
know about
yes there is if you were just working
out the numbers of what is the area
under this curve up to some point yes
you can absolutely figure that out the
numerical integral but to represent it
in symbolic form as a formula there may
not be a formula that is in terms of
functions you already know about that
represents that integral
well let's see
uh
question here
from spicy are there major changes to
design architecture or low-level code of
computers that are standard now
that uh i would change if i could
well
okay there's a couple of things to say
about that
first thing is
that once you have a universal computer
a computer that is programmable you can
program it to do anything
and or anything for which you can
program anything to do it
and so in a sense
however crazy
the machine code of a computer is by the
time you're building layers of software
on top of it eventually you can get to a
layer of software where it doesn't
really matter what was underneath
because the layer of software the
computational language let's say that
you have is optimized for the humans in
a way that they just don't see all that
weird stuff that was underneath in the
weird and wacky choice of op codes in
the machine code or or whatever else
so that's kind of the the most basic
thing to say
now having said that sometimes the
architecture can be such that the speed
of doing things is just way too slow if
you build those layers of software and
you really rely on having something
built into the hardware of the computer
that does something efficiently so there
are a number of things where i think you
know things have been done wrong
uh but classic is the thing called the
ieee floating point standard
um which i think is probably caused more
kind of bad things to happen in the
world than any other single computer
architecture uh idea
but uh so let me explain what that is
so if you take a number on a computer
and it's the number
four 3.782645 whatever it is i know
let's just take the number
uh
let's say one third one divided by three
okay
in well from language for example you
can just deal with the rational number
one divided by three you multiply it by
three you get exactly one
okay in a in a typical uh sort of
low-level computer system you would use
a so-called floating point number to
represent one-third what is that number
it's 0.33333
and the official mathematical number is
.333 with the threes going on forever
but in a computer you store the you can
only have a certain limited amount of
memory in which to store that number and
so the most common thing is to use 64
binary bits
so to to represent that number is
0.33333
with about 16 threes there and that's
all you get
okay so then the big question is well
what do you do
if you've got the 16 threes you know
roughly what the number is but there's
some error there are many numbers that
could have their
further digits could be different
but they're all represented by your
0.333 16 times number but after that it
could go on 333 or it could go six seven
eight one four five et cetera et cetera
et cetera there are many different
numbers that are consistent with being
the same up to the digits that you've
actually stored in the computer
okay so the question then is
what do you do with those digits you
don't know
well let's say you take that number the
.333 whatever number you multiply it by
three do you get one well no you won't
get exactly one because you you get one
but there's a potential error in the
value of one so to speak because it
could have been you have point three
three three let's just say it was four
digits that were being stored point
three three three no let's say three
digits point three three three and then
it could be after that it was zero after
that or it could be point three three
three nine nine nine nine nine nine
after that
okay so depending on which of those it
is you'll get a different answer when
you multiply by three and you and let's
say you multiply by three and subtract
one you'll you'll be you'll be seeing
only those those digits that you weren't
that were cut off when you store them in
the computer
okay so the question is what do you do
in that case
and the the issue is
do you give the user any indication
that
you are
having to essentially excavate digits
that weren't there
and
in the case that i just described where
you multiply by three and subtract one
that is essentially giving you precisely
digits that are unknown
but in the standard way computers are
set up with the so-called ieee floating
point standard you never know that
unless you've built sort of a harness in
your software that that carefully
figures that out
unless you built that harness the
computer just says oh the answer is two
let's say
and that's all you know and the fact
that that 2 or that 0.2 let's say
came from digits that just weren't there
they were just excavated from nothing
they the particular digit that came out
depended on the actual way that the
arithmetic was done inside the computer
and it was using this thing and it was
shifting bits from this place and so on
the actual number that came out is
complete nonsense every digit in it is
nonsense but you don't know that
um and so that's the way that computers
are set up right now is when they deal
with these these real numbers these
floating point numbers that are called
floating point because the decimal point
the number is actually ultimately
represented as
let's say it's 333.3
that will be represented as 3.3333
times 10 to the power 2. but actually
it's it's in binary so it's times 2 to
the whatever but um
it's roughly that so that's why it's
called floating point is because the the
decimal point is you're specifying
separately where the decimal point
floats to within the number the number
is just its digits and then you're
separately saying where the decimal
point is
okay so the issue is
that in the current way things are set
up you don't know
uh whether the digits that you got given
you're always given let's say you're
using standard 64-bit floating point
arithmetic you're always given
essentially 16 digits back the answer is
always 16 digits long now are those 16
digits correct or not you have no idea
and sometimes the computer could readily
have known that those digits are
definitely garbage
now in wolfram language we have a
mechanism for tracking the precision of
numbers so for example if you ended up
with something where all the digits
you've got would be garbage it will just
tell you that's a number of no precision
it's the number where there are
no digits now and it'll make a little
pink box or something it'll say zero
times ten to the uh you know times ten
to the four or something means there's
there's no digit no one up to that uh up
to that uh position
but the tracking of of precision like
that is something that takes more
computational operations because it's
not something built into the hardware of
computers it could be but it isn't this
decision was made in the late 60s early
70s and um actually i i certainly met
the person who was responsible for
pushing that decision
and um i i will say that you know this
is this is the way technology history
tends to work
is um
you know i'm like this seems like you
know this is this is not a good idea and
it's like well but you can do numerical
analysis you can do you can study the
algorithm you're using and you can find
out that it's not going to generate the
wrong digits well this particular
individual spent his career as a
professor of numerical analysis
so yes it's good for his business to say
everybody who uses a computer and uses
floating point numbers on a computer go
learn numerical analysis and go analyze
all your algorithms to find out if
they're going to generate sort of bad
numerical precision kinds of things well
of course nobody does that and so
actually what happens is people just get
wrong answers and they write down their
you know their the answer is 6.78462
actually all those digits are garbage
and and the computer and wolfram
language when you use our arbitrary
precision arithmetic mechanism um you'll
find out yes we know those digits are
garbage and we won't show them to you
we'll only show you the digits that can
be justified on the basis of the actual
computation that you did so that's an
example of something which i think is a
is a
one of those burnt in horrors
that really is not fixable at this point
and you just have to sort of paper over
it
um i would say that the um
the other big issue
in terms of the way computers work
well
i mean there are completely different
models of how computation
happens but i don't think it's that
important because you can build those
models on top of sort of the existing
low-level computer operations that's not
really a difficult thing to do
i think that the one sort of big area is
sequential versus parallel operations
that is does a computer just say i'll do
this then this then this then this or
can it do many operations in parallel
and increasingly modern cpus can do deal
with multi-threading and can deal with
having different sort of uh different
streams of instructions being executed
together gpus can do much more along
those lines well and they and they deal
with array operations where you're doing
something on every element of a of a
collection of numbers at the same time
the difficulty with parallel programming
is the programming part in other words
we humans tend to think very
sequentially we have a a certain thread
of experience that we go through we
think of time as being this kind of
one-dimensional thing where this happens
then this happens then this happens and
this case where everything's happening
at the same time
that's something we're not we're not as
familiar with i mean we can see in space
for example things can be laid out in
space and at different places in space
different things can happen at the same
time but it's much harder for us to
understand what's going on when multiple
things are happening and all interacting
with each other than when there's a
single thread of experience single
thread of time and we are i think it's
sort of a fundamental feature of the way
our consciousness works that we are used
to experiencing things in this kind of
single thread of time so when we write
programs we tend to really have a need
to sequentialize things like that and
people have for 50 years had sort of
experiments on making parallel
processing kinds of computers where many
things can happen at once the real
bottleneck there is for us humans to
understand how to program that and
actually it's something i'm actively
working on right now partly because in
the last year or so we've kind of
understood on the basis of our approach
to fundamental physics this kind of new
way to think about what i call
multi-computation
um the sort of multi-computational
paradigm which has to do with having
multiple threads of time rather than
just a single thread of time having
multiple threads of time and knowing
what kind of the aggregate effect of
having multiple threads of time is and
that turns out to be something deeply
related to our experience of physics
and one can i think maybe leverage that
experience of physics that we have to
let us be able to think about things in
terms of writing programs in ways that
we haven't been able to do before i mean
in a sense a lot of the way that we do
programming today
is based on the metaphor of kind of the
way that we explain things to other
people it's very sequential it's very do
this than that than that kind of thing
uh it's it's uh we try in in world
language for example a lot of what's
going on there is something that really
leverages the human ability to kind of
think about things symbolically to have
this sort of thing that is kind of the
the uh the description of something and
then you can take that description and
apply something to that description and
so on this is kind of the idea of sort
of symbolic functional programming is is
all about doing things like that and
that's a that's a very good metaphor to
leverage in thinking about how to
specify programs
so it is possible that the metaphors
that we have from physics
will be useful
in being able to write programs too and
that's something where because we are
used to things happening in parallel
different places in space at the same
time that we may be able to leverage
that to be able to more easily have a
way to
write programs that work in parallel now
but by the way i mean one piece of that
is already a solved problem which is an
operation on an array of numbers let's
say you have this whole list of numbers
you want to add one to everything okay
we understand pretty easily how to do
that it's really easy and more from
language to do that it's just you've got
the list of numbers and you say plus one
it'll add one to every number that's a
cognitively easy thing for us to do but
if i now told you each one of those
numbers i'm going to do this operation
and different things could happen with
different numbers and they're going to
be combined together then it's pretty
difficult usually
it's diffic it's difficult to have a way
to think about that so it's something
where we're we're trying to figure out
what is the right way to what is the
right sort of paradigm for thinking
about those things so that we make a
bridge between what is raw possible
inside the computer and what we humans
can do to kind of conceptualize what's
going on and that's a current thing of
interest which i'm hoping over the next
i don't know
maybe a year or so we will have kind of
this framework for doing
multi-computation that will make that
easier once we have that we may be
immediately saying oh my gosh i wish
there was a form of gpu that worked in
this way and i wish one could sort of
take these parallel threads and work in
this particular fashion but i don't know
that yet so i can't really say much
about that yet um so i think as i say i
think that the main
the main issue here um
is uh
uh has to do with um
um this uh
um
uh
yeah it's uh
that you know once you have a universal
computer you can program anything so it
sort of doesn't matter too much what
that low-level structure is
all right there are lots of other
questions here that are interesting i
let me try and do maybe one or two more
and then we should wrap up for today
zayden asks are there laws governing the
development of human history
you know people have certainly said that
from time to time hegel was famous for
for having this kind of uh idea of uh
you know sort of this this um uh
this
perpetual change in history and uh and
people concluded from that
diametrically opposite political kinds
of conclusions of uh i think it sort of
broke into the left high aliens and the
righteous aliens um that turned into
some of the less savory uh stories of of
uh of sort of uh of political
organization in the 20th century and so
on
but um the uh
the thing that um
the question is sort of are there
features of the development of society
the things that the way that that human
organizations develop are there sort of
necessary features of that
and you know one thing that's pretty
striking to see
we have in language actually we have the
data on sort of all country borders
known throughout history
and if you look for example europe where
there's been lots of well-defined
country borders for a few thousand years
you uh a couple of thousand years at
least
you can kind of look at the time lapse
movie of you know where did the country
borders move um in europe and it's
really strange to see because it looks
very much like soap bubbles or something
it's just like things expand and then
they pop and you know that was an empire
and then it popped eventually after it
took over too much
and it looks when you look at these
things it looks very much like
a physical or perhaps biological process
it doesn't look like this was millions
of people doing all these different
things in all these countries and all
this leadership and all this all these
armies and so on it just looks like
something that might be a bunch of soap
bubbles uh expanding and contracting and
popping and so on and that gives ones
kind of the sense that well then maybe
there should be sort of some kind of at
least statistical laws that govern uh
what um
uh how things work i mean it could be
that there are that there are such
things now now it has to be said that if
you look at
many different
kinds of properties of things you know
uh what are the sizes of different
countries if you rank all the different
countries in in order of that population
you know how populous is the most
populous versus the second most populous
first third and so on there's a
tremendous tendency for the nth most
popular to have a popularity of like one
over n or one over n to some power to
get some kind of power law distribution
like that and that's something you see
just across all kinds of different
things in kind of humanly set up systems
and and not so humanly set up systems
whether it's in uh distributions of i
don't know city sizes incomes this that
and the other lots of places where there
are these power law distributions
why do those come about
well there are a variety of method
mechanisms but they tend to be things
where there's some sort of hierarchical
structure and things sort of build up or
break down in a hierarchy you typically
get these kinds of power law types of
things happening although there are
other mechanisms for doing that as well
i mean they're they're that that's but
that's a common one
so
there are these statistical features
where you can't necessarily say this
particular city will be of this size you
can say the distribution of size of all
cities will look roughly like this and
maybe you can give some simple model
that can explain that and the model is
robust enough that you'll finally get
some result that looks like this
but if you ask the question
you know will
you know do empires always i mean in a
sense you know there are sort of truisms
like everything eventually comes to an
end and so if that if you believe in
that
which uh you know is really ultimately a
sort of question for physics of you know
does the universe come to an end and and
probably the answer that is no not
really um you know does things come to
an end when a black hole is in is uh
imploding you know eventually in a black
hole there's a point where time ends but
that's a that's sort of a rare case but
you know if you have a sort of an almost
truism everything comes to an end you
can have a lure of history that every
empire will eventually come to an end
but that's uh uh you know that's perhaps
not a terribly useful thing to say
if you ask a question like
uh does
you know people have tried to come up
with these kind of general laws of
history like you know once you have a
certain bureaucracy the bureaucracy will
get get ever bigger and bigger or once
you have a certain uh once something
becomes
commonly done it will end up becoming
structured and institutionalized and so
on there are kind of semi-anecdotal laws
that you can describe like that that i
think there probably is quite a bit of
of of commonality in the way that humans
operate in terms of those types of
things and it may not just be humans i
mean
just just to give an example here of of
both the an analogy and a difficulty is
biological evolution biological
evolution is also in a sense a
historical story you know there were
trilobites once there aren't trilobites
anymore there were dinosaurs there are
birds things evolved into things we can
even see all of that history kind of
laid out in the fossil record and the
question is is there a theory of that
history is there a theory is there a
theory that will tell us that there
should have been dinosaurs is there a
theory that will tell us that um
eventually you'll get um
an organism that will make a theory of
biology and so on you know what what
kind of things are theoretically
accessible or is biological evolution
merely a frozen record of arbitrary
history
well i suspect that there are general
laws and uh you know what
charles darwin figured out in you know
his 1859 origin of species book
was this idea of of evolution by natural
selection this idea that the the species
that survive the species will be the
ones that sort of it's almost a
self-fulfilling prophecy if the species
has more children then there will be
more of it so to speak and then that
will be the surviving species and that
that happens as a result of just the
environment acting on the species now
the true story is much more complicated
because the species acts back on the
environment the species acts on other
species and so on
but there is this general that there's
this idea
that there is this process of natural
selection we can see why you know when
we look back and we look at a species
that has this weird shaped beak we can
say how did it get the weird shaped beak
oh it needed that in order to open the
coconut or something and it was living
in a place where there were coconuts and
we can find in the fossil record that
first it had this shape of beak and then
it ended up with this shape of beak that
was we can now understand better for
opening coconuts
but the question is is there a more
general kind of less just explaining
after the fact theory for how biological
evolution works and charles darwin
thought back in 1859 he was pretty sure
there would be he was pretty sure as he
said i think the last line of his book
says you know just as the earth goes
around the sun according to the fixed
law of gravity so ever more complex
species basically are being and will be
evolved
now nobody ever managed to figure out
how to make a precise theory based on
that that's a thing we generally think
to be true but there isn't a precise
kind of formal theory that can describe
that actually some things that are
spin-offs from our physics project might
give us a chance to make such a theory
now um it's um that's sort of a new
thing but even these questions about why
is there so much diversity among
biological species why isn't there just
one winning species you know often in in
economic situations and commercial
situations there might be one winning
company takes over everything in a
particular domain
and it would be and so why doesn't
happen with species well sometimes it
happens a bit more and bit less but in
the end there are five or ten million
species in the world and why are there
so many
is it because the environment has some
particular form is it because of some
intrinsic dynamics of the process of
biological evolution
even why do species themselves form we
kind of think that's because you get so
the organisms are kind of moving further
apart and and they kind of they can't um
uh you know um
uh
and they get to the point where they
can't mate with each other and so on but
we clearly know that it's the full story
i mean you know we all have a certain
amount of neanderthal dna in our site
just looking at some new report for me
what was the number oh gosh i can't even
remember was it
i think i was i was uh it did say
you have
less neanderthal dna
than um
than typical
by by a lot actually than typical for
the um for the population uh on which
these tests are done which kind of
surprised me actually because i'm sort
of a northern european character and i
thought that was where the neanderthals
were were living i was a little
disappointed to not um feel more
neanderthal so to speak but in a case
but that's an example where where
clearly that that subspecies or that
that sort of what even actually
eventually became a separate species
there clearly was interbreeding which
we're all kind of in one way or another
beneficiaries of but in any case
the um
but so you know is there a theory of
biological evolution well there isn't
really we don't have one yet
there are probably pieces to that about
why the species diversity and so on um
and uh uh that that's a um
um
that's that's sort of a a separate thing
but i think that's kind of that may be
almost the test case for a theory of of
human history is a theory of biological
history so to speak
um i tend to think there's probably more
that can be figured out for theories of
human history um and there are more
things that uh you can kind of i mean
the the the record of people trying to
figure out oh we have this giant model
of the economy of the world and we're
going to figure out what if questions
about this and that doesn't tend to work
terribly well it hasn't traditionally
worked terribly well now you know
perhaps it's not helped by the fact that
there are humans in the loop
and once you predict something for
humans humans know the prediction and
then they act differently perhaps
there's some of that dynamic um i don't
know how important that is that's
certainly something people think might
be important in financial markets and an
understanding you know some method for
you know i've got this amazing loop for
buying this stock selling this other
thing buying this and so on i've got
this amazing loop i just run money
through it and i'll just make money from
nothing so to speak that loop tends to
close up because kind of other people
learn about that loop and the market
changes so that that loop is no longer
available and that's a consequence of
kind of the the the humans in the loop
aspect of it
loops in more sense than one
all right last last question for for
today may be um
it's a question here uh from baker
asking any tricks for reading textbooks
that maximize understanding of the
material
i will tell you that i'm probably a bad
person to ask that question of because
i
i really never read textbooks
sort of for the sake of reading a
textbook in fact if i do that i just
can't remember anything
i i always have to have this is a
question i'm trying to answer now let me
go and try and answer that question by
reading this book
and so
in
in a sense
and i don't know how generalizable that
idea is but in a sense even if
you go and you look at the textbook and
you look at some exercise in the
textbook and you look down the exercises
and you say you find an exercise you say
hey that one's interesting i'm
interested in that question let me try
and figure out you know how to answer
that question then you're sort of
motivated to go and look through the
book and try and fit together the things
you're learning with the thing that you
want to you want to answer i mean for me
doing projects answering questions
that's the way i meant i managed to
learn material rather than sort of going
through the textbook from page one
onwards i would say that the um uh you
know a way that um
uh i suppose for me okay my one of my
way of learning things is to try and
explain it like i do in these live
streams um these live streams really
help my understanding of lots of kinds
of material
because i'm realizing i'm i'm trying to
explain it and in explaining it i'm
understanding it better myself
and i would say that as you explain it
if you explain it and particularly if
you imagine explaining it
to perhaps somebody who knows
significantly less about the material
than you do you know if you're
explaining it to the teacher who knows
more you're going to say well of course
you know this blah blah blah
you know you never really have to engage
on the question of what's the
fundamental issue that you're trying to
think about here so i think you know one
of the things is can you break it down
to the point where you could explain the
material to somebody who knows a lot
less about it than you do
can you sort of simplify the material in
your own mind and in your exposition so
that you can explain it to somebody else
i think those will be methods for for
getting to the point of understanding
things now you know i've been myself
recently i mean the the topics i've been
trying to learn i was was trying to
learn a bunch about economics uh last
year i've i've that's been put on hold
for a little while now and i probably
will come back in a few months
um the um
i've been learning about philosophy and
the history of philosophy
and that's one where honestly i would
never be able to learn that if i didn't
have specific questions and sort of
attachment points of what i'm trying to
um uh trying to know about now a little
bit i'm also in that particular case
it's like well i've heard of this person
or this person or this person you know
what on earth
did let's say hegel for example you know
i've heard of him and i've heard of sort
of the meta things people say about him
and and then it's kind of like well uh
what did he actually say let me try to
understand that and i'm then motivated
to understand that just as a matter of
filling in my general knowledge because
it's something i vaguely heard about but
if you say here's this philosopher whose
name i've never heard let me tell you
about that person it's going to be
really hard for me to unders to remember
that unless it somehow connects to some
particular issue and philosophy that
i've been really interested in so i
would say that in that case for me
learning and i don't think i've
adequately learned the history of
philosophy um i'm i'm in a few couple
months i'll probably write something on
the relationship between the history of
philosophy and theology to um uh the
things we've done in our physics project
and and there
then i will understand it much better
because once i understand you know what
did heraclitus really say that we can
now have another that i now have an
intrinsic understanding of from other
things i've done i have a much better
chance well in this case very little of
that that's a bad example but let's take
somebody where the works survive like
emmanuel kant for example uh you know
what did kant really say about the
nature of space and time well now that i
think i have a good understanding of the
nature of space and time
it it i can now go back and say did what
kant said plug in how does it plug into
my understanding and then i have a
chance to to really
remember it and understand it myself
another area i've been learning is
immunology
that's an area where
well just reading the books is is like i
did try that
it's pretty you know i drown trying to
do that because it's an area where
there's a huge amount of detail that's
known about you know oh the cd8 positive
t-cell that is you know is signaled by
interleukin-2 and il-2 and there's this
pathway and that thing and that thing
it's like i don't know what's going on
you know i could probably memorize this
if i were you know going to medical
school or something and you know i had
to memorize it i probably you know i
have a i have a decent memory so i
probably could outright memorize it but
i don't think i would really you know i
wouldn't be able that would be a very
bad way to learn that stuff
and how how will i learn that stuff well
i've been i've been learning it but
partly that's because i sort of have
these little theories for pieces of how
the immune system works i wonder if this
works this way and then
i can in other words i part of what i'm
doing is getting to the point where i
could explain
how this works you know how does
the uh you know the light chain of an
immunoglobulin you know how does it
recognize molecules well then i have
questions you know given the particular
sort of sequence of transposable
elements in the in the genetics that
makes that uh you know how exactly is
that protein loop produced well not
produced i know how it's produced but
what is the diversity of shapes in that
protein loop and you know that's
something which with modern protein
folding technology that's existed for
the last year or so it should be
possible to actually enumerate what
those possible structures are like and
and then for me
okay oh yeah i forgot another critical
part of my way of understanding things
is try and actually write a program that
relates to what i'm trying to understand
so actually writing computational
language some some case of this so for
example in the case of immunology i
absolutely will try and take these
things and represent them and try and
see well what actually do these these
loops of protein look like and let me
generate a hundred of them let's see
what they look like let's see how they
would fit around an antigen you know how
a piece of antigen let me try to
understand how that works you know
there's some pathway here let me
actually get a graph that represents
that pathway and see what consequences
it has and so on and you know that
that's at least for my way of
understanding things if i can turn it
into a piece of i should have said this
i mean if i can turn it into a piece of
computational language then i really
understand it
if i can turn it into a piece of natural
language and explain it that's also a
good path to understanding but the
computational language part is a really
wonderful way to understand things and
by the way if you do that you probably
will understand it better than almost
anybody else understands it and the
thing that's really neat is once you've
understood it at a computational
language level it's not just you on your
own being able to make use of that
knowledge your computer is at your side
so to speak being able to make use of it
with you and that's a that's a really
powerful thing and and lots of things
i've discovered for example are a
consequence of of that kind of
methodology and it's it's really
remarkable i mean i i would say that um
uh well i i'm i'm um
take the example particularly one of my
kids who's a very uh sophisticated
computational language
uh user and so on uh when he was kind of
uh
studying things in high school and
college and so on you know
did all kinds of random courses and each
one it seemed like he would sort of take
random things that were coming up and
sort of turn them into computational
language and uh then it's like show them
to the professor and it's like oh my
gosh i've never seen something like that
before but it was trivial it was you
know once you've been able to translate
it into this sort of powerful medium
that is a very new medium you're able to
jump further than people have ever seen
before and that's a really neat thing to
be able to do and it's also really
really good way to truly understand the
material so that's some uh that's a few
comments on that um i think uh as i say
i'm i've i've got this this case right
now because i'm i'm kind of about to
start talking to immunologists about
trying to understand things about
modeling the immune system using using
methods that come from our physics
project and i'm a little bit shy to
start talking to immunologists until i
know the kind of basic lingo of uh how
the immune system works because
otherwise it's like somebody tells me
it's a helper t cell and it's like i
don't know what that is i do know what
that is now i have known actually that
one for a while but um uh you know or
getting confused about sort of basic
aspects of it i've got to get to the
threshold place where i can actually
have a a reasonable conversation um even
even if i'm not going to know or not
even going to care what all of the you
know what all of the particular surface
proteins on cells are and what all their
particular names are and what particular
tricks the innate immune system has
learned in in rebuffing different kinds
of uh of of things that can attack it
that doesn't really matter for the kinds
of things i'm trying to think about so i
i need to know a little bit of that as
sort of general background knowledge
because one thing when you study some
one of the things that happens when you
study things actually there's another
point to make is that every field has a
way of thinking about things
and it's different from field to field
so for example i was just doing actually
a a
thing that probably posted a uh
interview discussion
with a chap called judea pearl who's uh
worked on um
uh probabilistic reasoning and
probabilistic
uh modeling and uh causal models and
things like this i was i was just doing
a
discussion with him and um
one of the things that's interesting is
that somebody who's worked on sort of
probabilistic and statistical things and
about the way that sort of cause and
effect works in those domains there's a
certain way of thinking about things
that one develops from that and it's not
one that i have so it's one that i kind
of have to try and absorb but it's a
different way of thinking so for example
typical cases in economics let's say or
an evolution of biology both things if
somebody says i see a bird and it's got
a red beak okay to an evolutionary
biologist or i see a red a bird it's got
a red beak it eats birds with or it has
um
i don't know it it has a a um a
parasitic uh worm i know a a a symbiotic
um
uh you know insect that has greenly you
know green wings and does this or that
to leave an ocean a biologist there'll
be a way of thinking about that that
says well if it's got a red beak and it
does this then there'll be more of those
of that species than this species
because that's just the way evolution
works because they've got a way of
thinking about things like that in
economics it's like why did somebody do
this
well in economics it's often well
because there's this sort of rational
thing that you're doing that's
maximizing this utility of this and
there's a way of thinking about it
same same thing in lots of other fields
there's sort of ways of thinking about
things and sort of penetrating into the
way of thinking about things in a given
field
is is one of the big challenges
and i think in my experience the best
way to do that is just doing examples so
to speak learning about things and often
thinking about them the way you were
thinking about them and then seeing how
they get thought about in that field and
seeing sort of the the tweak to the way
that you were thinking about them that's
the way of thinking about them within
that field and within the particular
sort of methodology and and uh and
cognitive framework that exists in that
field i mean in in um in mathematics for
example uh
people you know just sort of a almost a
joke type thing
is people say oh i'm trying to prove
this thing i've got this mathematical
thing and the mathematician will say
well well what about the case of zero
what about the very trivial case that's
a sort of a a thing in that way of
thinking about things well start with
the trivial case let's look at it for
that case that's sort of a thing you
might do whereas in another field it's
like you know in biology for example
it's uh you're thinking about this you
know let's think about the case where
the woodpecker lived at the top of a
skyscraper you know that's a corner case
but that's not the case you'd think
about you'd instead be thinking about
something that would be very different
from the kind of mathematical way of
thinking
anyway
all right well i think that's probably
um it for today
but thanks very much for lots of
interesting questions we have more saved
up for next time and i look forward to
uh
to getting more questions and um
seeing what i can do to answer them and
uh
and exercising my method for learning
things which is in this case trying to
explain them
so thanks very much